we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here is i'm trying to understand this
voicemail so hopefully you can help me i
believe that this is a conservative
hispanic caller
who says white progressives are the
worst and i think he's talking about me
even though i'm hispanic
i think that as a hispanic um
white progressives are the most racist
uh
i think you white progressives need
to stop telling
we
hispanics or people in color in general
of what to think
this is just another form of slavery
that you're trying to attempt here so
let me i'm i am going to say
an example where i agree with this
caller okay but then most of this
voicemail is a dumpster fire
one of the things i don't like is
something that has been imposed
by mostly white progressives
and that is latin x rather than latino
latina okay
latin x
i am a progressive
and i am also hispanic
and i don't like it i don't know
any actual hispanic people who use that
and so i've said before
latinx did not arise
uh
naturally
from within the community
it was sort of like imposed by uh mostly
white progressives and that one thing i
am against but most of this voicemail is
bonkers you're not only trying to tell
us what to think but how to think i'm
sorry homosexuality is wrong abortion is
wrong so this is a conservative hispanic
individual so why don't you white
progresses just simply
leave us alone and stop brainwashing our
people thank you bye all right well
listen um there is a large poor i mean
it should be said
that along with jewish folks overall
uh hispanic americans are quite
progressive that's actu that that's the
truth of the matter and so
don't blame white progressives
for hispanic voters being in favor of
legal abortion and being in favor of gay
marriage uh most of these positions we
came to on our own so kind of a weird
caller pretty unhinged
with like one tiny little fraction of a
grain of truth there we have a great
bonus show for you today
we will talk about the passing
of uh the last soviet leader gorbachev
mikhail gorbachev who passed away at age
91. we are going to talk about
california fast food workers very close
to winning some historic protections and
we will talk about the incredible viral
video of a black pastor
watering his neighbor's flowers
and the police show up and it is crazy
crazy video
all of those stories and more when i am
joined by producer pat on today's bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad yeah
well you can judge for yourselves when
you sign up at
joinpacman.com you can use the coupon
code big voting22 to get a discount and
i will see you then